hello welcome another appointment
a daily for the press online
and live on ubs
it's the 22nd friday 29th january
stéphane i know you're very
impatient to start answering
questions about health but at
least wait until i  have finished announcing that
someone is asking you a question so
like every friday i would like to
start with the president's agenda
for next week on wednesday
after chairing the
college meeting president sandra line will
give a speech at  the
conference case and uc towards a new
ecological social contract by
videoconference or videoconference as we
say in good French on Thursday
it will make a speech at the event m du
numérique 2021 organized by detours
from europe also by videoconference
finally on Friday the  president
will receive mr jean yves le drian
the french foreign minister
vein haye would like to inform
you may sandrine de co  mmissions john
reid who confesses astrazeneca gridda who
contract signed by twingo partys
antoine is our guest twenty speak in the
process of the thing is united states
this weekend and push notification
yes yes like an exploitation transfer
thus against bellucci bull trust open
series  have begun their decline the
dummy bomb and its vaccines
we have it crisis note verbale online
store chris willis contains not
the same commission
[Music]
even if all this is strictly coming
from such information
then I would still like you  recall
that commissioner didier reynders is taking
part today in the
informal video conference of ministers
of justice on the agenda is a
debate on the protection of vulnerable adults
an exchange of views on criminal law and
the protection of intellectual property
rights to which  will also participate
the commissioner il va joensson as well as
a debate on the digitization of
justice a con  press conference with the
das police station is scheduled for around 5:40 p.m.
and I therefore invite you to ask all
your questions related to the agenda for this
meeting during this
press conference finally before moving on to your
questions I would like to remind you again
that we will have  two more
press events for you this
afternoon first at about 3:15 p.m.
executive vice president valdis
dombrovskis and commissioner stella kia
who are falling will come here to the
press room to introduce you
to the vaccine export transparency mechanism
immediately  after we will have a
technical briefing to the strikers on the
same subject and with these we can
move on to your questions and I start
with mauzé vague when this week brings to
the auto descat on its building new exports
its peers these mechanisms the spectators
of  to enter what would lead to
impose itself in export cars on the axis
thus all its eyes a little too much on the
cd the real roots in s  es studios
same sex in the emirates of winter x games
help and yielded 6.21 this tourist r2 is having
fun species of warblers
information sports foundation booster the
symtoma fabrice hyber from east
russia but this time in five years says
have commissions relating to this
sad Saturday because in all the same
baltard style to interact with the diploma with the
pros games
yes its content of a deaf
saint cloud makes that stéphane
collet museum who brought me here targets
as for flat  forms of helped
explain that me wade is at 6 10th either
gone evening bound for
eastern communications with six nations
and nationals like everyone it's
all this art and design helps
vaccinate when you earn 5.5 ue  on
the ethos continuo andy expired vaccine
vaccination
angela
the italian commission for d'emergency
arcuri justin a state of the modern at 15
announcement of the tour of italy supervision
of art and action ovation by this
communication is very hard well
commission  base  t modern of the pieces the
management all they cooked modern
stéphane huneault a golden man of
leader of the spurs is of
Toulouse company of the six tickets are marked
by staff commission to know and run it
with facebook stories bas the dispersion
of books i swim two the  other side
five high islands
indeed a thing that tries you should take
your time to go under contract the NGO human
rights in said theo klein position to
provide extensive how we live
specific against the internships vote yes
before the trial of hunt
indeed many  in france
which are mansion astrazeneca its
locality
in the united kingdom n 23 6 10 complaints
we continue to be afrika all of breeders
including two hours
stack one of them absolute we what this figure
at 7 and 6 watts life contraction stream
yes  yes to convince date otherwise you are there
you exist holding princess
develops settlers libido leopard sodect everything
is recommended to beat him here on which
you remind itunes if the state of his holding
or not of  an
authorization by life marketing quote beats like a
crazy bwin rugby dog ​​on two companies
avoid new vaccines witches
manufacturing at risk winch visa n 10
against very soft ate of 2.6 in short a
life authorization so as to be and well you
respect  empty their chargers
as a demonstration an authorization is normal
from lynwood out that we have fun with the
company and that does that we have alder
everything is absolutely against that of
nantes is 19th exists now let's move in
everything tommaso gala boxes itx giant of the
letters which  he was published dubai to
present to the quincunxes where jean-michel
it is therefore necessary to madame woods
strong president of the n12 possible to the
other articles have between 30 and or to the
two girls or to add in 2002 and
ecology
the apricots and is it possible in us
in our techniques exist or
adopt deceptive licensing and which is a
light by day initially stupid reds
were not disappointed that things m they
say major is this  because we are
possible is possible
list this madness any guy
continues to do so and indeed you have even
among the wafers everything said nasri dialogue
with company so far wilkinson
collective force which left at 2.5
[Music]
we ourselves  we will see at the end of the match like
this one who say we are told all
work in to b cyclist of meetings on
sunday with also the companies
dino context to be in return of during
[Music]
of meetings and bye bye defense mohamed
terme  de ce standing starting annette
mix to be seen the context of the line
up ten minutes and I sat down and
john c dante or bi trans analyzernx
supporting clean development and
mary spencer green racing handel
vaccine boots on our feet this weekend at a
contact with  andy on a daily bread we
say die in the chocolate and find ways
vivax in that it would be placed also at
810 times which says it all yes vaccine
feeling is distributing and a complex ex cop
extreme sports its  decision
younes series your lease without contact
queens and day is required
[Music]
yes because I now give the floor to
virginie go ahead virginie yes
on fire we said that finally
weeks of increase linked we would be
able to say if indeed they  have
done 100% of scheduled deliveries this
week they have come back to
something to standardize second question
i take it from the question that was
asked earlier which you did
not answer on moderna is that
modern has problems kate the italians and
already be a big problem or is one
of the more general delivery problems
of production and delivery of the generals
third question there are several
member states france portugal spain
and I  surely forget others who
announced that he was reviewing
their vaccination campaign in certain regions
because there were not enough doses
to ensure a second of a
second injection you computer what c
and lover who  are in the process of
rescheduling to completely slow down
their vaccination campaigns because
because they passed the vaccine for which I have
three questions please thank you
virginie I pass the floor to stéphane
hello virginie on the question of
price louis when  I say so the company
had announced two of the deliveries that
the deliveries would again
would take place again at 100% we are
following up with the member states
the week ended risk but my
deliveries therefore take place in the
deliveries take place on the basis of contracts
concluded between  society and the member states
we are in the process of monitoring I can
not give you at this time also
very precise figures on this but we are
monitoring the situation in the case of the
streaming board
with regard to modern oh yes m
you did  reference to the concern expressed by
the Italian authorities, as I have
just explained, it is quite possible that
in the context of relations between
dead states and the society of discs  if we
happen on the delivery that it would be quite
possible this kind of situation we
have today commission a guest
we commission that the member states
who sees delivery problems
with companies to put it on the table
to discuss it with us so that  we
can follow we have a story
board whose budget among other things to
follow this kind of situation thank you stadium
I can not say more I am not
sure if I understood correctly the third
question is what we I think of
the  question is do we
wait for the 7 before we conclude
prison programming us and
channels in regards to their
vaccination strategies given
the problems with vaccine deliveries
that there may be initially as you
well know  embarrassed vaccination
programs are
national competence programs member states are
best placed to see which
priority groups are to be vaccinated how to
implement o  implement vaccine programs
based on specific situations
in all member states
we are all together in this
same fight i will go to get the
vaccines quickly so that we can
move on to vaccinations 7
member states to implement their vaccine
program  vaccination we
have moreover, as I explained before,
coming from the recommendations in mid-October
already on the preparation of this kind
of vaccination programs on our side
we are obviously trying everything we can
do to ensure
rapid delivery of the doses to which
the states  members need and so
we follow these situations together
with them among others in the case of the
style bordering the
tvq thank you I think I [ __ ] up you have
to hear wave asia yes no but in
fact the question is is is it was  not
that the third question already goes on
the first two could not
always send us the peering
you told us that we would do a
poi  nson father it's
friday do the first five days of the
week have the first four
days it's friday noon
went according to plan
it's not just a state story launched
by cani i'm  not able to deliver
there will be a drop in the first
week and the second week
a normal level have they
respected this commitment game
i don't understand you can't
answer us this question modern art i
'm sorry i think  that it's not
just a story of orders
between the member states and the
laboratory either it's that there's a
global problem of production
insufficient modern a or not that's
where it's just a  problem
between italy and modern art I think it's
a question that concerns you it's
not just the member states and finally the
third question was several
member states in the old style their
programs and their
vaccination campaigns because  they don't have  s
the others they were supposed to have
you tell them what it's still a
subject I would say to all the
European citizens who are waiting for
these doses who have their appointment
canceled
you can't settle for
tell them what we are with but virginie I
believe that if we type last some
last question the fact that there will
be a press conference this
afternoon on an accompanying measure
concerning the authorizations for
the export of vaccines  outside the
territory of the European Union
shows that we are in dialogue with
the Member States on the measures to be
taken to ensure that the
vaccination programs can count
on the doses of vaccines which are provided for
in our agreements with the various
companies
secondly, of course, we are in
daily contact with the member states
on this subject, but not all the tools
are in the hands of the
commission, are we?  s our
essential role has been to set up a
negotiation mechanism with the
companies that supply the vaccines
so that the Member States can
then place orders and order
and receive the vaccines
they need, which they therefore need on a daily basis
within  from the steering board
we are discussing with the member states
on how to optimize the delivery of
the vaccines we know that there are
difficulties but we
are working on it to resolve them and
I think that the member states will code
it  know perfectly and understand
very well that there is a need
for joint work it is not us
who simply want to tell them do
this do that the problem will be
solved
it is necessary that together and with the
companies  we managed to quickly
increase the delivery of
vaccine doses as to your question on modern
a first the summit girl is not finished
it is four and a half
days ago seven  days in the week
and therefore at the moment we are
not able to
answer this question precisely and
we will see to what extent we
will be able to do it
later
aegon how to live aid
a neighbor vicious circle  many
headlines and gbagbo alive
washington and tactics briefing com yes
to what china while transcending
says
we have in any left and enjoys
kompany lescott delivery the vaccine this
short-term lease 500 d'alcine this noon
benefit customer profits  griselda
thank you very much sorry and i'm
sorry by my camera i don't have what happens i
would like to go back to the question of
the item without sold the only time
i believe it was used was
in a crisis  economic
if I understand correctly there the proposal
it is to solve a
sanitary question is what you are sure
this article for is a dog to be
used the zelda we
do not have any how  area to be done
on article 122 as such and its
use I believe that I have explained
clearly what our position is with
regard to the best way of
cooperating with the industry to arrive
at the right result therefore as far as I am
concerns
we believe that there are better
ways to achieve his ends he has
no particular comment to
make on these
I pass the floor to when a yes for
eric I do not put my video to
avoid exploding
just a quick question about the
schedules for the deliveries who
was editor was it a
request from the wind band commission
of astrazeneca what these
documents it is the formation that has not made
public and  the other question is since
the British eyelashes are mentioned
in the agreement in a direct way is
that the commission is in contact with
the British authorities to find out
what is happening in particular for dad by
the inspections
thank
you thank you account 1  as far as
we are concerned we have clearly said from the
beginning that we are in favor of
maximum transparency on the contract
and that except of course and sale for
questions of two security of
course it can be legitimate for a
company in certain  case of request
and that certain elements remain
confidential for good reasons
of 2 as we call it in French
already belgium the ex of secrecy of business secrecy
but therefore in general we
wish that the contracts are
made as public as possible and therefore
as far as we are concerned there would be
no problem that other
clauses could be revealed but
obviously there was a dialogue with
the company on this subject with
regard to its second point our
interlocutor
it  is the company and it is therefore with
it that we dialogue on the way in
which its industrial tool can meet
the needs that we have david I do
n't see that didn't take away d  so I'll give the
floor to david yes oh yes thank you eric
still on the contract I wanted
because I'll get them to him very quickly but I
'm not an expert in law or two
pharmaceutical contracts
I wanted to know where can we
find if  it is possible
the obligation for astrazeneca to
start producing and storing the
doses before and is and where can we
find the
[Music]
the risk in terms of production which
is assumed by the European union as
I  I told you I am going to do an exegesis
of the best of the contract now it
seems that there is a notion that the notion
of managing and risk producing and us
manufacturing forgiveness manufacturing and
risk that you will find in the contract
but I do not know  exactly here to
which hacker the article and who refers
who refers to your question about the fact
that the companies are supposed to produce
before having obtained the authorization to
be able to start delivering
the doses from the moment
where permission was given and it
also obviously shows that the
commission is well aware of the fact
that things can be produced and
then not be used
if permission is not given just a
clarification on moder bas because  that it is
important in the debate which has been a
little bit emotional at the
moment in italy but not only in
italy
if I understood
correctly you have not informed you
of delivery problems to  member states
that's right that's clear you didn't
get the information from modern that's
how it is thank you I'm going to speak stéphane out of
7 on this issue thank you massimo
guarini concert model to the only
thing I can say c  is that the 7d of the
possible delivery problems are
the subject of discussions at strict noon at
high streaming
so we are discussing it at this stage this is
therefore with the aim of arriving at the bridge to
fully understand if there are problems and
to  see what to do  e if
necessary
thank you but once again I believe
that it is important to underline and to
questions on the manufacturing and
risks and it is also shows it is
that it is by nature a process which
is complex and where it  it can happen that
there are delays
what matters is the quality of the 10
between the members of good steering and
the company on the reasons for these
delays and the measures that the company is
implementing to try to overcome them  to
answer it
try it is the role of the steering bowl
with the member states therefore to dialogue
with the company on its aspects
louise new show squash meeting this plan
for are media come seamless
pin saint jo llopiz times wait said
exact  tarbes said
they are 200 detainees throw mr segan
feeds all the forces explains t he
I v6 our meeting between them
to look into immediate life and fuel
went from 12 to 26 of his shares before
all clean around the body of
[Music  ]
vaccination and our assets  inaria date
hugh laurie
baratelli boots say life raison
d'être
next made in france at
aristide meetings crisis on sunday
they all know the egos you know what
to position on discussions
say in sawn off and precise poles
forests are eight years old  and a half
ok the demigods then soyuz with a view
to signing contracts
we have we are calling we are better off
approaching is static at the briefing
hollywood icon and tactical at the briefing at
one 15 minutes in two expressions
or pride in time  in its in 2010 fails
in evidence qdr furnaces what do you have
if not compact boots in austria where
they were vaccinated game and I pass the
floor to isabelle
no in fact I am going to lower normand
because it was a question on the
contract so I  will ask all their
part in gpa and in new york a problem
christian yes hello two questions the
first the letter he addressed to
michèle leaves today in the
public domain in fact fact re  response to
the concerns of member states who
are very concerned, as you have
addressed, about all the different problems
they are encountering on the deliveries
of vaccines that have been pre-ordered and
we feel that there is a kind of nervousness
but at the same time  an annoyance
vis-à-vis the commission and we feel
that some member states
are wondering if it was really
worth letting the commission carry out a
European operation if it would not have
been better for everyone to do something
in his corner
the danes 10 years down after all if you
had to pay a little more
for vaccines but sure to
have them would not be better off so are
you aware today that
you are playing a very big game  with
the member states who would be tempted to
say we tried
something european in skills that
are ours it failed and it is better to
do as mr orban does,
i.e. take a vacation  cin of which we do
n't know a little nothing but ensuring the
vaccination of its population
that's my first question it's the
relationship you have with the
member states who are worried and need to
know is my second question it's  is
with British people
can you confirm that an
investigation is underway to find out if
indeed part of the
production of the two sites which are in
the European Union has not been
repatriated to the United Kingdom thank you thank you
very much on  your first on the first
question
the european union took charge of the
coordination of the coordination of a
negotiation on behalf of 7 to
members with producers of vaccines
pharmaceutical companies
i would like to remind you once again that
this negotiation took place  made with the
participation of the Member States the
negotiations themselves
with representatives of a group
of Member States and secondly that all
the contracts have been validated
by all the States  ats members who then
had the possibility if
they wished to make an
opt-out therefore of he reserved the
right not to participate in the purchase of
certain vaccines and they all to my
continuous knowledge wished to
continue in this in  this way
we have a governance mechanism
which is like for the way
in which we implement this this
European vaccine strategy is what it is
easy certainly not is what the
member states of course express
concerns just like us absolutely
and that  is perfectly normal in the
current circumstances but and that is
the absolutely fundamental point we must
forget we must not forget that if we
had not negotiated its contracts at
European level there would certainly be
Member States which today would have
zero  vaccine 0 vaccine and that from this point
of view European solidarity has
enabled the European Union
and all the Member States to obtain
ir contracts for the delivery of
sufficient quantities of vaccines i
absolutely do not deny the fact that there
are questions to be resolved and
processes to be
worked on in order to ensure that the
availability of the vaccines which are in
the contracts are improving and that's the whole point
of the dialogue we have with
some of them like astrazeneca
set this week but I think
it's when you're in the middle of the
process that you have to  the crew and
the crew it is the commission and the
member states remain united to
arrive safely and it is on this
that we are working
on your second question on is there an
ongoing investigation at the level of to
know  if there would be doses that
would have gone to the united kingdom
I have no information on this subject
pass the floor to stéphane in case he
has something to say no I think that
I have nothing to say  to say
what is important is you would have
done only with good transparency
with regard to the production capacities
of the company
but I have nothing to add indeed
concerning investigations which would have
convinced would not take place
in this field thank you what is
important perhaps christian to
complete it is that  the mechanism which
must be adopted this afternoon and
which will be presented to you later so
I obviously leave the primacy to the
executive vice president and to valencia which
decimates the technical briefing afterwards will
serve us precisely to
obtain information on the export of
vaccines outside  from the territory of
the european union
but you will have more details in the middle
of the afternoon
i will give the floor to samuel yes hello
eric not to mention investigation
is what you asked where was
informed by the
belgian export authorities of  vaccines by
senneff factory this pronounced fncf craze
towards great britain
given the new
post-bac site trade rules
it would seem logical that from the
January 1 Belgian customs can
have access to this kind of information
so have they sent
you anything on this subject thank
you thank
you there is indeed in terms of
there are statistics colleagues of
course  which are made at the
customs level of the Member States as soon
as products leave the territory
of the European Union, but this does
not mean that the information reaches the
European Commission
once again we are going to decide
this afternoon to  the establishment of a
mechanism that will allow us
to obtain this information
on the export of vaccines outside
the territory of the European Union and
I now give the floor to
louise again to agree a problem  david
maybe on another topic if there
are other topics for the four
minutes we have left before moving on to the
briefing on the contract itself david
go ahead yes thank you
cwi another topic it's competition it's
at the  italy we read on the
italian press that
there is and there would be a need
for a broken loan john excuse me 200
million euros is there a notification
thanks to nothing hello eric hello david
i think  that the other day the commissioner
the workforce vision is stable she has
already taken stock of alitalia
I have nothing to add for the moment as
always we are we are here to discuss
with the other members
if as they constituted must
be granted in line with the
European rules on state aid and therefore
I would like to refer you to this fifth
madam st gall said the stay thank you
very much
paula thank you eric sim question for
nothing still has italy but another question
the commission today  today
[Music]
we are going to be very hard on any media
that has become a hockey soldier 1 yes yes
this time stone stasse from our book
[Music]
gast friendly we say we de contract john
allan green it or to one minute
ok jump to  ulysses michael x